en 16 cents et quelques en angleterre il
eu une période trouble dont on ne sait
pas grand chose
le roi jean régnier on l'appeler sans
terre car il habitait chez les autres
deux personnages seulement sont dignes
d'intérêt
le shérif de nottingham un militaire
ambitieux mais cruel et son ennemi
acharné
robin des bois un justicier implacable
qui parlait aux oiseaux et aux arbres de
la forêt de sherwood rogen et chèvres je
parle aux oiseaux à t'acheter préparé un
petit civet de chevreuil à la sauce
ciboulette et au vinaigre de bordeaux
zai tout me revient de nulle part et on
a compris que le salon rené bouin 2000
bewkes a agents temps déjà ricaner les
imbéciles et ils ont piqué la vaisselle
les salons et l'argenterie et les vidéos
non large entre les rideaux je les ai
données attention série il est avec le
mot et de soudards quoi c'est soudeur de
plus que de rapidement nous et je pense
être canal
c'est l'iphone devant foutez vous aux
cartes à bande de petits salopards
sumatra au joli petit chèvre avec un
petit rideau sur le dos ça c'est mon
mari qui lui a donné
mais elle est très sexy toute cette
petite chèvre là surtout avec son petit
rideau sur le dos ça me rappelle mes
vacances en algérie
allez les gars et quand j'en rideau et
puis on l'achève
à l'erba il lui tout ce qui nous
appliquer
[Musique]
rien pourtant tu avais toujours tout
écouter me présenter ma force
[Musique]
parti avec le soutenir dans ce jeu sorti
en fumée
[Musique]
quand je pense qu'il est venu jusqu'ici
égorger nos chèvres et nos compagnes
on est ajusté comme un pur sang impur
abreuve nos sillons dans ça j'aime bien
ce que tu fais tu devrais en faire une
chanson là bas j'y pense alors à table
citoyens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]